all right before we dive into this
episode the minimalist want to help you
declutter your glowing screen so head on
over to the minimalists comm slash
wallpapers to download any of our free
minimalist wallpapers including our love
people use things wallpaper for your
smartphone or computer enjoy
Miller writes in I don't know what I'm
passionate about help this makes me
think of uh I mean I always point to Cal
Newport when I when I think of people
struggling with their passion he wrote
two really good books one's called deep
work and the other one is called so good
they can't ignore you and those came out
an opposite order of what I just listed
them right but uh but yeah Cal Cal talks
about how you know following your
passion like that is it's bad advice
because we we assume that there's just
one thing that's supposed to just like
spark this excitement and that we go to
bed excited and then we wake up and we
think about that thing we wake it sparks
more excitement and then we're just
getting excitement spark throughout the
whole day that there might be someone
out there who has had that happen to
them but I can certainly say like I love
what I do and Josh I I know he loves
what he does we put a lot of work into
what we do and it's cultivating
something that we do have an
appreciation for it's something that we
do love but there's a lot of work that
goes into cultivating that passion and
the beautiful thing too is like you know
I love to snowboard I love to mountain
bike I love to longboard there are so
many things that I can cultivate that I
can put my time and effort into so you
know I think for my advice for Miller
here would be you know find that find
something that interests you and start
putting effort towards that don't don't
it don't look in the mirror and be like
all right Miller what is your passion
you've got to come up with this one
thing that you're just gonna be and now
you're stuck with it for the rest of
your life yeah as well all right so can
you you have people come to you and say
hey I don't know what I'm passionate
about yeah well let me give quick
context and then I'm gonna tell Miller
how he can actually figure this out
so I appreciate Cal's work I've
interviewed Cal and Cal's right when he
says and there are other people that say
don't follow your passion but they're
not giving you the rest of the sentence
so I teach on talent and passion every
day they must intersect and they must
both equally be at play so for instance
don't be the kid on American Idol who
you have an empty passion to be famous
but you can't sing okay that's what
Cal's talking about and other people say
that's what they're really talking about
absolute but they're throwing a little
bit
and so I with all due respect I want to
teach this because you got to understand
passion is huge it's not enough on its
own it's marrying what you do best
raw talent think of a think of a bunch
of clay just a lump of clay right now I
don't know if you've ever seen a Potter
actually take a lump of clay and put it
on the wheel and do it it's fascinating
stuff this is what I teach we take the
raw talent
meaning everybody's born with some
things you're good at multiple things
but there's a there's a handful things
you do better than anything else that's
what we're talking about identify that
because Miller's got a look at that
first because within what he does best
are the clues to what he would love to
do most absolutely so I always start
there with my collar well let's just
look at what you do best and human
beings don't like to do things we suck
at unless it's golf it's one of the few
things I love golf but it's about
camaraderie the cigar on the back nine'
a little bit of bourbon and every once
in a while I'll hit a good shot oh by
the way I'm in nature and it's gorgeous
right but I largely suck but I keep
doing it that's a hobby right yeah so
that's not profession that's not purpose
all right now then we look at the other
side which is passion what do I mean by
passion is this a fleeting feel-good
feeling no no no no no no I love this so
if you look at the root word of passion
it means to struggle mm that's where it
comes from the Greek and so it means to
struggle so what does that mean well
what they meant was is if you're willing
to struggle to be able to do this if
you're willing to struggle to be willing
to see the results of the struggle
that's a passion
yeah that's meaning that's significance
that's what we all long for so so we
look at that so that's what I mean when
I say passion like that the work you
look forward to the work because you
guys look forward to what you do do we
have hard days abscess stinking lutely I
do but we look forward to it now here's
here's the other part when we're engaged
in it oh I got the juice I got the juice
even when I'm sick you turn the mic on
for me and I know I got callers on the
other end that need clarity it doesn't
matter how I feel guys I got the juice
yeah it's not about me okay now when the
show's over no matter how bad I feel or
how tired I am or what's going on my
personal life or if it's been tough
meetings in the rest of the day
in those moments after the show and then
when I lay my head down on a pillow at
night there's terrific meaning in the
results of the work alright now that's
there for everybody so you use what you
do best to perform the work that makes
you come alive now how do we figure out
passion well the first step is as I told
you start to identify your talents
really easy thing to do yeah stop
thinking and start feeling what if
people always complimented you on what
subjects or little skills or things
always just came easy to you saw other
people struggle with it but was easy for
you write that down take that list of
some people in your life that are truth
tellers they're not gonna make you feel
good like the mom on American Idol who
told her kid or whole his whole life
maybe he's seeing so good and the kids
sucked and it took him embarrassing
himself on national TV for this poor kid
to get some truth in his life so please
don't be that person
go to people in your life who know you
well and will tell you the truth right
so then we get clarity on what we do
well then let's imbue and be willing to
accept the truth well yeah yeah by the
way that's the whole point you need to
see you as the world sees you so put
some years your life now how do you dive
into the passion thing well we've got
the clues on what we're good at so then
you answer these three basic questions
all right it's a psychological exercise
I'm rewording the same question three
times first one is who do I most want to
help and just think about that mm-hm
put a face on think about them who are
they who do you most want to help second
question what problem do you most want
to solve go back to that first question
one of the problems that those people
are thinking about have I mean get
specific mm-hmm are they single moms or
struggling financially in public housing
and they they don't feel they have a way
out why why do you have that and when I
ask callers that it's always personal
well my mom is a single mom and I
watched my mom struggle oh now we're
getting somewhere right now the hearts
are revealing true passion the why
alright then the third question is what
solution do you most want to provide
again this is more of it's a little
different take but it's like I get
jazzed about this solution I love
creating apps that make people's lives
easier fantastic that's great that's a
worthy
oh okay great that's if I could do that
all day every day program apps that make
people's lives better
oh man that's incredible so let's not
overthink this passion question answer
those three questions and by the way I
recommend a pencil and a piece of paper
here's why it will clarify your brain
when you take it from the brain and you
write it down we know from psychological
studies that the brain begins to see
those things the brain takes pictures of
what we think about this is a real thing
go look this up this is neuroscience and
so whatever thoughts we focus on the
brain then becomes like this Robocop
roving camera that begins to look for
the things that are verifying our
thoughts it's true let me give you an
example psychological study on this
we've all bought a car at some point in
our life or we were with our mom and dad
when they bought a car you know and we
all went to the lot and we got all
excited about the car we're all focused
on that car big deal we get in the car
on our way home we see that car 17 times
and the next day we see it 25 times and
at some point all of us think or say to
each other see in this car everywhere I
didn't see it last week it's crazy how
many people have this car why focus
whatever our brain focus is on ok
whatever thought sorry so this is a this
is the power of thought whatever we
think about our brain then and goes and
looks for that thought and we'll go find
things that we never even saw so so this
is powerful step back on this so when
you truly begin to answer those three
questions who do I most want to help
what problem do I most want to solve
what solution I most want to provide it
might start at 50,000 feet then we wake
up the next day and we look at it again
and we get that old eraser out right
we'd have to worry about an ugly page
and we rewrite it and the next day and
the next day the next day and before you
know it it's gone from 50,000 feet to
it's right in front of me and I never
saw it before and this is not mumbo
jumbo folks this is what I tell my
callers every day and it works and we've
got the emails and the social media post
and it worked for me
so if you're trying to figure out that
sweet spot the intersection of what you
do best and what you love to do most
those are the things that you have to do
get very clear on what you do best and
now these are the tools we can use the
answer how do I do this over here well I
happen to be really empathetic and I
just a great listener and I'm a pretty
good communicator okay great let's write
this down then let's go over here well
it turns out that I'm I'm really
passionate about helping children okay
what children what are the problems well
you know they've had abuse oh okay why
is that well I was abused oh okay see
from great pain comes tremendous passion
yeah so we have lots of clues is my
point I just I just gave you the whole
loss that's what like quit with the ED
that process is that's how you cultivate
a passion like that is yeah I think
those are the steps and I've never heard
it explained so well man that was
perfect it's pretty simple to me and the
other thing too is like what I was just
you know kind of reworking on my head
here with cows with cows take on it is
passion is not the beginning no like
passion is the end result and going back
to what you first said about where you
know comes from the Greek word I mean
which means to struggle yeah like the
passion comes from the struggle the
passion the the focusing on the passion
that might drive the motivation it's the
fuel yes so look at passion as the fuel
for achieving your purpose but not but
not the yes but not the sana destination
right yeah
you